support move university and the
production of more video tutorials by
making the financial contribution or by
getting yourself one of these t-shirts
details under the support move section
of move University calm the link will be
in the description below thank you and
enjoy so the third matter law that will
be talking about is the law of multiple
proportions so who stated this law it
was John Dalton who actually comes up
quite a bit in chemistry so keep him in
mind what is his loss a law says that
elements can combine in different ways
to form different chemical compounds
whose mass ratios are simple whole
number multiples of each other that's
complicated what does that mean again
we're going to check out the examples
but there are some key words I want you
to keep in mind okay so well actually I
need on keywords but key parts the first
part is that elements can combine in
different ways to form different
compounds okay different ways different
chemical compounds so let's look at that
first we'll get to the whole mass ratios
part later so you have carbon and oxygen
two different elements they can combine
more than just one way they can they can
make carbon monoxide which is just Co or
they can make carbon dioxide which is
co2 right same two elements different
compounds right depend on the way to
combine hydrogen and oxygen can combine
of course we've seen to get to give us
water right but they can also combine to
give us h2o two which is hydrogen
peroxide right which is different than
h2o and nitrogen and oxygen can combine
to give us n 0 or no2 which is so we
have nitrogen monoxide and nitrogen
dioxide okay so we've got different
elements right elements combining in
different ways to form different
chemical compounds carbon monoxide is
different than carbon dioxide water is
different than hydrogen peroxide that's
your monoxide is different than I should
I dioxide so that's the first part of
this now whose mass ratios are simple
whole number multiples of each other
what the heck does that mean well it's
due the example with with this one here
let's use this as an example so
let's look at water first so h2o h2o has
two grams of hydrogen / 16 grams of
oxygen okay so we've got a mass ratio
for H for hydrogen to oxygen being 2 216
okay so we think about that make that a
little bit neater so we've got a mass
ratio a hydrogen to oxygen mass ratio of
2 to 16 which we can simplify to 1 2 8th
right so this is D this is the hydrogen
to oxygen mass ratio in water right h2o
now h2o two hydrogen peroxide has two
grams of hydrogen per 32 grams of oxygen
so there we have a mass ratio of two to
32 which is simplified to 11 / 16 which
means that we have an h2o mass ratio or
hydrogen to oxygen masks ratios has to
be less confusing in hydrogen peroxide
of 116 so now what we're going to do is
we're going to take each of these mass
ratios take this master it loops right
take this mass ratio for water and this
mass ratio for h2o two hydrogen peroxide
and we're going to divide them okay so
we're going to take we're going to take
let's see if I could just change this
color here something let's do is do
orange so if we have waters hydrogen to
oxygen mass ratio is we're going to take
that and we're going to divide it by
hydrogen peroxides hydrogen to oxygen
mass ratio so the 14 water was 1 over 8
and the one for a hydrogen peroxide was
one over 16 so we have 18 / 1 / 16 so
that's just if you have two fractions
multiply by the reciprocal so 18 x 16 /
1
give us 2 over 1 so this is our ratio
the idea here is that we have a small
simple whole number whole number ratio
right that's the simple and that's a
simple idea i bind the second half of
the statement right whose mass ratios
are simple whole number of multiples of
each other right so we have a ratio of
two to one and that's basically the law
of multiple proportions I would
encourage you to try doing the same
thing with the examples here with CNO
and N&O hope that video is helpful thank
you for watching don't forget to hit
that video with a like if you found it
helpful or enjoyed it and be sure to
share with anyone else who you think
might find it helpful also if you'd like
to support the channel follow move
University on the different social media
links Twitter or Facebook all that stuff
links in the description below thanks
and happy studying